anyway questions uh we have a lot
tonight Jim Jordan has announced a new
joint house investigation by the way
into that deal but make no mistake this
is now a two-part Scandal it involves
serious bribery allegations against the
sitting president of the United States
and a cover-up by his Department of
Justice that has been politicized and
weaponized that same doj that throws the
book at his chief political rival that
guy's name is Donald Trump and meanwhile
remember Hunter Biden's pricey portraits
of a crackhead well we have breaking
news at this hour John Solomon's
editor-in-chief just thenews.com some of
those masterpieces paint by numbers
might have gone all the way to China all
right here with reaction house oversight
committee chairman James Comer house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
all right this is an important day
Congressman Comer I'll start with you
let's talk about the major takeaways
today and how real of a bribery scan Joe
Biden bribery Scandal allegation is this
well every day this bribery Scandal
becomes more credible I mean let's look
at what Devin Archer testified today he
said that uh that Not only was Joe Biden
on the phone over 20 times with people
including the barisma executives uh
talking about uh whatever even though
the president denied that he never spoke
to any of these people he also said that
Hunter Biden was under immense pressure
while they both served on the barisma
board to call Washington D.C immediately
and try to get shocking fire that's the
Ukrainian prosecutor and not many days
later Joe Biden traveled to Ukraine and
we've all seen the video that where Joe
Biden brags about withholding foreign
aid to Ukraine in exchange for uh the
the Ukrainian president firing the
prosecutor who was investigating his
son's corrupt Energy company let me let
me let me make sure we have the timeline
here so this is December 2015. if I'm
not taken uh that that that meeting took
place in in Dubai and Zola chesky was at
that meeting the owner of Barista had a
barisma and it was at that meeting they
were desperate to get help from Joe
Biden is that a fair assessment
that's a fair assessment okay and then
immediately thereafter Joe traveled and
right after that Joe Biden I have the
tape you're referring to Let's remind
people
had gotten a commitment from poroshenko
and from uh yats and yuk that they would
take action against the state prosecutor
and they didn't so they said they had
they were walking out to Prescott said
no I said I'm not gonna or we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money well son
got fired
son of a b they fired him James Comer
that's a quid pro quo Sean that's very
illegal we have evidence in this sworn
testimony that uh that from a fellow
barisma board member that they were
pressuring Hunter to immediately get on
the phone with his father and get this
stopped so wow you know the evidence
continues to mount and today we saw Joe
Biden has lied to the American people he
knew exactly who his son was getting
those millions and millions of dollars
of wires from and he spoke to him and he
spoke to them often and the son
complained bitterly that he had to give
half his income to Pops pay for his home
repairs Jim Jordan let's get your
takeaways but 20 times uh calls with
these foreign business partners about
the weather and the 1023 form actually
quotes the barisma CEO as saying that he
had to pay he didn't want to pay but he
paid five million and one Biden 5
million or another Biden and it's going
to take 10 years for you guys to figure
out where that money came from
hmm
yeah Sean but it's all an illusion
according to the Democrats I'm gonna go
back to that meeting that you and Jamie
were just talking about this illusion of
access they're having a board meeting in
Dubai on December 4th 2015 after the
board meeting Hunter Biden meets with
Devin Archer zolachevsky and pazarsky
the two key guys who run barisma they
meet for drinks during that meeting they
say we need the U.S government to
intervene we're under pressure from the
prosecutor we're facing pressure in
Great Britain because they've sanctioned
and seized our assets 23 million pounds
of 23 million dollars in Britain we need
some help they make a phone call to D.C
Mr arches I don't know who they call but
they call DC and five days later
December 9 2015 Joe Biden is in Ukraine
and he gives a speech starting the
pressure on the prosecutor in Ukraine
five days after that meeting five days
after a phone call to D.C five days
where they use the Biden brand according
to what we've learned today the Biden
brand was the value Hunter Biden brought
to this business Arrangement that that
took place simple
and then of course we know yeah the
brand the brand was totally Joe Biden
the guy with the power and the
connections in D.C but five days after
that this this conversation takes place
this speech takes place and then a few
months later that clip you just played
shoken gets fired that's how serious
this was let's talk Jim Jordan about the
brand let's connect this also to the
1023 form and and this is a very
credible FBI informant because the FBI
deemed that person informant they paid
him a fortune and apparently used him to
testify in certain cases so they have
this credible statement meeting with the
CEO quoting directly the CEO of barisma
Hunter's dumb as dirt his dog is smarter
than Hunter and it's they're paying the
money that he doesn't want to pay and
that you're never going to be able to
trace that money for 10 years are you
going to be able to trace that money
well Mr Comer is working on it we're
working our staff's working on the
oversight committee chairman Comer
that's what we're trying to do figure
all that out but here's the takeaway I
have today too Sean I thought today's
testimony from Mr Archer gave a whole
new like to what happened last week
remember last week this deal they put
together that the judge said No Deal
we're not going to do that because it
was unprecedented never seen anything
like this the deal they put together was
designed to keep barisma out of it
remember they didn't they weren't going
to charge for 2014 2015 tax years they
were going to do the felony charges that
there because that's barisma money and
the Pharaoh allegation the fairer
concern derives from this this action
that took place in Dubai where Hunter
Biden is talking about how can the U.S
government they're asking Hunter Biden
how can the U.S government intervene and
help us in this situation so now we have
some some more light on that terrible
deal they tried to put together last
week and why the judge appropriately so
asked questions and it's no longer going
to happen 20 times the the that they put
Joe Biden on the phone was to talk to uh
uh make pleasantries with Hunter's
friends uh and not assert or or assure
people that that his the father was
going to be helpful to these companies
what other reason would they pay an
admitted addict all that money uh James
Comer can you explain the how does a a
an admitted addict make all that money
what what services then was he offering
if Joe was not the brand
well Devin Archer testified that they
were influence peddling we've wondered
what the business was I suspected it was
influent peddling but we heard today
from someone on the inside it was
influence peddling they sold Joe Biden
that's what the business was and Joe
Biden himself talked to every single
person that that has wired money to the
bideness I mean you've got a situation
here where you look at those people who
were wiring the money a lot of those
people aren't the most credible people
in their countries there are a lot of
people who are in a lot of trouble in
many of these countries who were sending
wires to the Biden family they needed
help they needed help from the
government that's why they paid the
Biden family they were influence
peddling and what Jim Jordan just
mentioned the the Pharaoh violation
that's foreign agents registration act
we know that Hunter Biden has violated
that even the judge in Delaware last
week cited that as one reason why she
rejected the sweetheart plea deal but
what this did today in my opinion is
just opened the door did Joe Biden
violate the foreign agents registration
act because he was an active participant
in in at least one deal we know of with
with the barisma deal he was actively
participating in doing a benefit to this
foreign agent for this foreign country
and he was withholding American tax
dollars in the form of foreign aid for
that I mean this is very serious today
took a huge step towards implicating Joe
Biden in many of these crimes we're
going to continue to press forward in
our investigation and Jim Jordan Devon
Archer admitted Barista would have gone
out of business if not the brand and Joe
Biden was the brand uh you know again go
back to the WhatsApp message you know
and now it brings us to your
investigation in the Judiciary Committee
not investigations about whether or not
this department of justice is weaponized
is this Department of Justice with Chris
Ray and Merrick Garland is it being
weaponized against Republicans and are
they protecting the Biden family
Syndicate are they protecting Joe Biden
do that why didn't they want to hand
over that 1023 form knowing how damning
that was why were they so why was it so
difficult to get suspicious activity
reports
and God bless this judge last week who
asked the right questions the court
there in Delaware looking at I would
encourage people to read that transcript
and go through there what she asked
because she said has this kind of
agreement ever been is this
unprecedented and the answer was yes it
is yes it's never happened before so she
I think laid it out how how wrong it was
that they tried to put together this
type of deal uh and I think that
demonstrates how the justice department
uh is has been frankly turned against
the American people and not applying the
law in an equal manner like they're
supposed to in our great country so we
want to talk to these people now there's
a 30-day time frame so we're trying to
get and talk to many of the people who
were in that that famous October 7th
meeting that Mr shapley and Mr Ziegler
talked about when the whistleblowers
came and testify we want to talk to
people in that meeting we want to talk
to others involved in this investigation
but we'll see how this next 30 days
plays out as they get to uh the new plea
agreement whatever that's going to be
let me tell you and this is why the
Republicans that have one half of one
house of government uh at one branch of
government is so critical because these
investors would all get covered up and
both of you have put your neck on the
line to get to the truth and we went a
long way today and uh this will you both
answer yes or no do you believe that
this is now officially the Joe uh Biden
bribery allegation and do you believe
that you will be able to prove that Jim
Comer
I sure hope so and I I do believe that
there's a lot of smoke and with their
smoke there's fire we we just heard
testimony today that Joe Biden had lied
to the American people Jim Jordan do you
believe that do you believe the doj has
been helping to cover it up
well it sure looks that way and I would
say this Joe Biden said he was not
involved there were two dinners at the
Cafe Milano in DC one of them as you
pointed out where where Joe Biden was
there for the entire dinner both times
one of them had Mrs batarina this
Russian uh the wealthiest woman in
Russia worth over a billion dollars so
that sure is a different story than what
he's been telling us all along
all right great work both of you
appreciate your time both Jim Jordan
James Comer thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else